jean le camus et bonsoir merci d'être là
tous les deux est-ce que vous sortez
beaucoup dans les boîtes en général ça
c'est une bonne question et lâche non
parce que nous avons beaucoup
d'occupations entre paris notre bonne
ville de rouen
c'est pour ça que ça me fait d'autant
plus plaisir d'être dans une autre
histoire
la dernière fois que j'ai chanté dans
une boîte c'est quand je suis direct ça
fait huit mois
or on est au banc que tout ne dira pas
que c'est vraiment très très longtemps à
5 ans et mon mari ne s'est peut-être pas
alors je vais demander à certains de vos
proches comment vous deviez vous
habiller alors souriez vous côtoient un
petit peu oui
oh non mais j'ai l'idée est complètement
démodée je crois qu'il faut s'habiller
selon les circonstances les moments de
la journée
selon les activités d'ailleurs jacques
ils se moquent souvent de moi parce que
même quand on est tous les 2 n va
changer dans quatre fois par jour de
manière d'indiquer
ramenée du temps tu vas tu as préparé en
avril il est comme tous les hommes
politiques on écoute on nous inquiète
tous à radio en même temps alors sa
double de là dedans bien sûr du temps de
la discussion sur la couleur de la
cravate
on va parler sur la première discussion
de notre journée on a parlé de choses
sérieux que jean le camus et est ce que
finalement vous n'êtes pas un homme
politique catholique alors que vous
devriez être un catholique hommes
politiques français déjà une question
très compliquée carrément je déclare
chrétiens et en excusant pêcheurs oui
voilà comme celle ci pour pour vous fait
valoir tout toujours le même
ouais sauf depuis que je suis sérieux il
m'arrive je peux chez ma soeur mais moi
pas si on peut pas être parfait
c'est la difficulté de répondre à votre
question vous dites-vous catholique où
c'est vrai chrétien oui parce que je
trouve que l'idée d'amour et la pub la
plus merveilleuse qu'on puisse donner
aux hommes
je reviens de pub a été donné depuis ce
message
en même temps c'est c'est un peu lourd à
dire et à porter parce que on se sent
tout à fait en deux sets 7 idéal ce que
je viens simplement c'est que vous
donnez l'impression d'être en politique
avant d'être catholique alors que quand
on est dans votre situation j'aurais
pensé que vous devriez être catholique
avant d'être homme politique
moi je suis athée sont appelés homme
politique voulait dire par là que mes
yeux politisation de son bras mais vous
savez c'est une manière de servir les
autres et de vivre passe comme ça tu
vois que ça intensément son existence
ont d'elles pas être quelqu'un ou
quelque chose qui flotte
mais qui espère ou outils à l'illusion
de de composer un peu à la marche de
l'histoire
est ce que finalement la tendance
politique que vous incarnez l'un par un
petit peu abandonné à la gauche certains
vidéo parce que finalement les droits de
l'homme ont été inventés par
jésus-christ le pape à condamner
l'apartheid le racisme est ce que c'est
pas des idéaux qui ont été récupérés un
petit peu par là par la gauche
aujourd'hui est ce qu'il ya une
démission du haut jura rangs de la
gauche communiste la gauche un bon la
gauche fantaisistes c'est vous le dirai
socialiste ça si on ne sait plus très
bien ce qu'elle est mais je crois que
nous ferions mieux de nous rejoindre
[Musique]
quel que soit le bord où la rive où nous
nous sommes situés en effet pour servir
l'homme sa dignité mettre la personne
humaine au dessus de tout chaque homme
est unique
voilà si messi est une idée pour moi
fantastique c'est de regarder chaque
personne comme un être unique
il remplace et chaque rencontre et tout
moi une découverte c'est pas quelqu'un
je croise une manière banale
j'ai envie de le connaître de le voir la
lumière de ses yeux avec le petit espoir
qui les sert à trouver là typhaine la
petite mia est temps pour nous aussi
nous avons envie de vous connaître parce
que moi je pense qu'au delà de l'image
que vous pouvez avoir dans l'est dans
les médias dans la vie politique depuis
un certain nombre d'années
je suis sûr que vous êtes beaucoup plus
riches que les que l'image que donne de
vous les médias
toutes les images appauvrissent est tué
elle fige elle fige un aspect ça devient
une affiche et
vous êtes l'homme par exemple des dents
blanches
voilà voilà c'est une figure alors ceux
qui les aiment noir donc non pas
regarder quelqu'un d'autre enfin on vous
fîtes une fois pour toutes sur une
affiche un instantané devient
perpétuelle faut le savoir le supporter
et accepter des rencontres comme celle
que vous m'offrez dans l'espoir que on
voit un autre aspect tout à fait
président lorsque lorsqu'on vous parle
de vos adversaires politiques
vous répondez que ce sont les
socialistes et les communistes mais
jamais les dirigeants du front national
alors n'est ce pas qu'ils aient su
lorsqu'on est un démocrate chrétien
comme vous je pas que contrairement à
monsieur le pen
ce qui fait que la france est la france
que c'est différent d'autres pays
c'est elle a la capacité de faire une
synthèse de la diversité regardez la
france même si avec la radio la
télévision les différences provincial
cette nuit ce qui est beau ce qu'il
bossait des bretons des basses plaines
normand d'être alsacien la france et
tout ça c'est une mosaïque mais s'est
posé il fait un tout alors monsieur le
pen il ne comprend pas bien ça vous êtes
unis steve df en 88 donc soutiennent
plutôt jacques chirac que raymond barre
alors que ferez vous est ce que vous
allez démissionner ou à lorsque où est
ce que vous allez les exclure de l'aider
alors hein
j'ai un principe ne jamais démissionne
jamais je n'ai jamais c'est le meilleur
moyen de garder son job
jamais jamais jamais démissionné c'est à
vos conseils que je donne aussi vous
voulez non mais vous savez on aura des
vicieux est une forme de lâcheté qui
s'est jeté les pompes
c'est abandonner ses foutent le camp moi
je suis toujours resté là où j'étais
quelquefois peut-être un peu trop pop
steen et sur mes convictions mais vous
dites que donc lui d elle va soutenir
raymond barça c'est donc tout le monde
j'ai ma prévision à vous pour apporter
son savoir est ce que vous ne trouvez
pas que raymond barre slovène petit peu
l'udf en faisant cavalier pour sa
campagne électorale
alors qu'est ce que vous faites a voulu
rappeler qu est ce que vous lui faites
la résidence et bien j'attends qui
découvrit le découvrira parce que c'est
un observateur être très très attentif
qu'il a besoin de ne pas être tout seul
madame lecanu est ce qu'il est vraiment
démocrates à la maison votre mari je
sais pas est ce qui laisse faire ce qui
vous laisse un petit peu dirigé la
maison où est-ce qu'au contraire il est
à la maison aussi directive qu'est
l'amérique
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous moi je
pense que oui c'est à vous de répondre
moi aussi mais en réalité je crois qu'il
a aiguillé politique extrêmement
absorbante
beaucoup de tâches diverses et que la
mise en ce qu'il a envie de trouver
c'est un cadre qui soit esthétique il
est sensible à l'esthétique certaine
douceur de vivre un certain art de vivre
et comme nous avons un peu les mêmes
goûts nous opposons maintenant dans le
dit parfois on a un dynamisme
divergences instant buts ça ne sert à
rien c'est à dire
au peut désirer intentionnellement des
choses différentes je vous laisse pas
chercher mes bagages je vais les
chasseurs chercher mais en réalité je
crois que c'est un homme qui aime ce que
des êtres qu'il a autour de lui sauf un
novice qui prône mans vous avez déclaré
je n'irai pas au sommet parce que je
n'ai pas le goût de tuer
c'est vrai j'ai dit ça un jour mais je
crois que c'est françois giroux voyez de
qui je parle
qui un jour a dit de moi que je ne
pourrai pas aller au-delà de ce que je
suis
parce que je n'étais pas capable de tuer
elle pense
elle a malheureusement pas de tort que
pour beaucoup d'hommes politiques il
faut être un tueur a tué attention il ya
des caméras qui nous regarde pas des
assassins
je veux dire être capable d'aller
jusqu'au bout de la tâche riz de la
dureté pour terrasser humilié détruire
l'adversaire
sachez pas très madame lecanu et je vous
présente michael delmarquette un qui est
un mage gens je vous présente michael
delmarquette un match très savants et
qui a étudié à partir de votre lieu de
votre heure bien entendu de votre date
de naissance votre thème astral alors
mage est ce que jean le camus est un
avenir politique parce que c'est la
question finalement qui nous occupe tous
ce soir
est ce que dans les astres tu vois pour
lui un avenir politique surtout avec
l'échéance de mai 88 alors justement
mais 88 peut représenter une date
importante à la mesure où ou jean
lecanuet poisson attendant poisson donc
le l'arrivée de jupiter dans le signe du
taureau peu
être assez importante dans sa vie
politique est toujours à tu le vois je
pense résidents n'ont certainement pas
un président non premier ministre à mon
avis non ministre ministre certaines
ministre s'est déjà fait vous arrivez
manner m'est déjà arrivé plusieurs
plusieurs fois mais il n'y a pas
longtemps en 86 vous avez failli être
ministre la défense non des affaires
étrangères donc tu penses que tout ça
peut recommencer encore je pense que
s'il ya une opportunité à saisir elle
n'aura dû emmener en mai en main et tu
te bases sur quoi pour vous dire ça sur
la présence de jupiter de trigone de
jupiter avec le soleil des gens du pays
à ce moment là à ce moment où ce n'est
ni son montant n'ont hélas en 1965
lorsque jean le calvez se présenter à la
présidence de la république
est-ce que cl tu avais connu tu aurais
pu le prédire l'issue de cette élection
oui certainement on pouvait dire qu'il
n'avait aucune chance d'être élu alors
non ce n'était pas à cause du général de
gaulle c'était à cause des as à cause d
un prix absolument
ces derniers n'étaient pas connues et à
ce moment là un carré de de pluton est
de stature ne vous laisse une chance en
fait mais je pense que c'était une
oeuvre une étape importante pour votre
évolution personnelle
le fait de se mesurer au pair en fait le
fait de provoquer en quelque sorte de la
paternité
politique et spirituelle de de gaulle
est ce que je me trompe pas je ne me
sentais pas pour être élu non je peux
souhaiter tout à fait impossible je me
présentais pour une idée que maintenant
pratiquement tout le monde accepte mais
qui à l'époque était refusé par presque
tout le monde c'est la communauté de
l'europe la construction de alors
maintenant derniers points de cette
astro view vous semblez tous les deux
faire un couple très très unie alors en
termes d'amour mages qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire du couple lecanu et à long
terme sentimentaux oui jean lecanuet est
un grand plus de 10 alors est ce qu'il
est vraiment tu dis pas tout j'observe
une censure prudente
est-ce qu'il doit garder jama par
exemple il donne avec un pyjama à mirka
billets de tuner il a probablement grand
d'extériorisation de sentiments des
chaleurs et sympathique ira et qui
correspond à sa pulsion profonde mais je
crois que mia côté intense presque
religieux qu'elle fournisse de son
essence et qui ya recours
que peux-tu ajouté match sur la vie
sentimentale du couple lecanu et j'ai
l'impression que les travaux domestiques
des travaux ménagers seront très
important dans sa vie qu'elle et son
image comme l'a expliqué la semaine
dernière que pierre juquin c'est un
écueil est un bouquet d'églantine sur un
chemin de montagne or jean lecanuet
tue-le traduirait comment alors il ya
deux images que j'ai proposé la première
correspond son soleil c'était un homme
nu jusqu'à la ceinture écoutant du bois
savons pas c'est un degré de travail
donné les moyens répond ah oui quand on
voit que pas si mal ce bar je vous est
arrivé de kant et au canada coupe du
monde est quand même bien j'ai une
seconde image à vous proposer c'est un
cheval et son cavalier tombe en
franchissant une des allées degré de
catastrophes entreprises aventureuse
passion pour les plantes et kiev écoutez
c'est vrai aussi en direct par le nombre
de fois où je suis tombée de cheval le
tuvalu derrière cette chère mais avec la
passion de l'équitation et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous il mettait un coup de boule